salut romain tard bah oui mais quoi
c'est pourquoi j'ai pas eu non pas un
truc hein
voilà attends je vais t'expliquer vous
savez maintenant partant du principe
qu'on ne parle bien que de ce qu'on
connaît vraiment j'aime bien tester
différentes techniques pour mieux vous
en rendre compte
après le grand âge la cryothérapie
l'isolation sensorielle le détatouage au
laser j'ai décidé cette fois de le faire
refaire les dents ça m'est venu comme ça
mais avant de parler reconstruction il
faut parler destruction parce que c'est
là que tout se joue et que c'est
important d'avoir les bons réflexes
alors imaginons vous déguster une
boisson fraîche dans un lieu festif
une bagarre éclate et vous tentez de
vous interposés pour éviter aux
protagonistes des dégâts qui pourraient
être achetés d'ailleurs à ce sujet je
vous remets le lien vers la vidéo sur
les dangers des coups violents au visage
s'est apparemment le message n'est pas
bien passé donc
imaginons toujours bien sûr votre
mission est couronnée de succès puisque
la rixe prend fin rapidement mais dans
la confusion de votre dentition a
malencontreusement heurté le front d'un
des belligérants
nan mais imaginons résultat le lendemain
matin vous vous réveillez et sauf que le
mieux c'est de pâtes en hollande
une dent c'est ça à l'extérieur c'est de
l'émail en dessous c'est la dentine il
voir si vous préférez est encore en
dessous c'est la pulpe qui est composé
de vaisseau et de nerfs ça c'est pour la
partie externe celle qu'on voit dans la
bouche qui s'appelle la couronne et puis
en dessous dans les gencives ya des
racines et en cas de souci c'est
l'étendue des dégâts qui va déterminer
le type de soins en gros si la clé n'a
été touché a priori ça va c'est pas trop
grave c'est superficiel ça doit pouvoir
se rattraper facilement avec un matériau
composite spéciales dont vous avez
sûrement déjà entendu parler sous le nom
de résine si les mailles et la dentine
sont touchés bon c'est un peu plus
embêtant mais ça va encore pouvoir s'en
sortir avec une résine ou en remettant
le bout de dent cassée en place à
condition d'avoir gardé dans des bonnes
conditions
mais ça on va en reparler après vous
vous en doutez si la pulpe est touché ça
devient un petit peu plus compliqué
alors si vous voulez fixez vous regarder
à l'intérieur de la dent cassée
si vous voyez un petit point rouge a de
grandes chances que ce soit ça mais en
fait le seul moyen de se faire une vraie
idée sur l'étendue des dégâts c'est de
faire une radio panoramique dentaire ne
serait ce que pour voir si les racines
ont été touchés alors du coup comment ça
se répare il ya trois grandes options
soit on vous réimplante votre propre
gouttes dans our vote dans carrément
parce qu'elle a pu être expulsé
complètement soit on vous remplace le
boutis banque avec un matériau composite
soit on vous la remplace avec une
prothèse de couronnes dentaires
oui en général les gens appellent ça
juste une couronne vous vous souvenez la
couronne c'est la partie visible de la
dent donc qu'est-ce qu'on remplace est
ce qu'on met à la place ça s'appelle une
prothèse
donc on l'a vu ce qui détermine le choix
de telle ou telle réparation c'est
l'étendue des dégâts et notamment un
critère qui est super important est ce
que ce qui reste de vote dans et viable
c'est à dire est-ce qu'on peut le
laisser comme ça et juste reconstruire
autour ou est ce qu'il faut le
dévitalisées avant ou alors carrément
est-ce qu'il faut tout enlever et mettre
autre chose à la place parce que de
toute façon tout est mort donc s'il
dentiste détermine que niveau vitalité
c'est ok il peut directement vous coller
une résine ou une prothèse de couronnes
en ayant juste préparé un petit peu le
terrain avant par contre si la dent est
pas viable
il a dévitalise avant c'est-à-dire qui
retire le nerf et le reste de la pluie
si la dent est trop abîmé mais que la
racine est intacte on peut glisser dans
une petite fiche de métal avec un petit
bout qui dépasse sur lequel on vient
fixer la fameuse prothèses de couronnes
on appelle ça un petit niveau par contre
si la racine et casser il ya de grandes
chances qu'on soit obligé de tout
retirer et de remplacer tout ça par un
implant en ce qui me concerne par
exemple les racines ne sont pas touchées
mais la dentiste a préféré attendre une
dizaine de jours avant de se prononcer
sur la viabilité de mes dents pour
pouvoir choisir la meilleure technique
de restauration
oui la restauration on dit comme ça
aussi moi j'aime bien ça me donne
l'impression d'être une espèce de
tableaux anciens
bon du coup je suis obligé de me
trimbaler comme ça pendant dix jours
benjamines de sourire parce qu'en plus
d'être moche ça fait peur aux vieilles
dames et ça donne pas l'air très malin
non plus avant tout ça avant d'en
arriver là qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
sur le moment c'est à dire pile quand on
se casse une dent la première chose à
faire c'est d'essayer de récupérer la
banque a sauté ou le morceau de dent qui
a été cassé parce que comme je voulais
10 est possible de les réimplanter mais
à deux conditions
d'abord la conserver bien comme il faut
et ensuite pas perdre de temps ensuite
si vous saignez si vous la bouche
d'abord et après mordait dans un truc
propre genre une compresse clients 4
donc si vous en avez pas sous la main
une serviette en papier et une propre
après si vous avez retrouvé votre dent
metella rapidement dans duke sérum
physiologique
ok vous n'êtes pas forcément du sérum
physiologique sous la main si vous
n'avez pas ça vous pouvez aussi la m
dont hull est ok vous n'avez pas
forcément du lait non plus dans ces cas
là vous pouvez la conserver directement
dans de la salive la vôtre soit dans un
récipient dans lequel vous aurez
préalablement cracher soit directement
dans la bouche
alors attention dans ces cas là faites
attention pas l'avaler parce que sinon
le temps qu'elle ressorte pas ce sera
trop tard pour la ré affronter ensuite
filé chez le dentiste c'est considéré
comme une urgence donc par définition
sans rendez vous mais passé un petit
coup de fil avant quand même pour
prévenir que vous arrivez ou alors fait
appeler quelqu'un qu'ils dosent
autrement que vous aussi vous êtes gênés
si ça vous arrive la nuit là ils vous
respectent les urgences
attention pas dit qui puisse vous
réimplanter votre dent à moins d'avoir
un service spécialisé qui gère les
urgences de nuit mais au moins ils
pourront vous faire une radio vous faire
des soins calmer les douleurs
éventuellement et vous donner des
conseils pour la suite alors petit cas
particulier mais qui arrive quand même
si votre dent a été entièrement expulsé
avec ses racines et où vous procéder
exactement de la même façon c'est-à-dire
europe dans le sérum phy
dans l'est la salive ou dans la bouche
surtout pas dans l'eau plate parce que
ça la vie vraie et il ya trois choses à
savoir quand vous retrouvez votre dent
tenez là toujours par la couronne jamais
par la racine
parce que sur les racines il ya des
petits résidus jaune et ça c'est des
ligaments et c'est hyper important qui
reste en place parce que ça augmente les
chances que la réimplantation prennent
les délais pour l'art et implanter c'est
encore plus court que pour un simple
goutte dans idéalement pour avoir le
maximum de chances que ça marche on va
faire ça dans les 20 minutes une heure
alors malheureusement c'est rare de
pouvoir respecter ces délais mais vous
avez pas plus que quelques heures devant
nous alors 6 maximum donc les pêcheurs
du coup vous pouvez essayer de vouloir
remettre en place vous même pour gagner
du temps pour ça si elle est sale vous
l'a relancé en la passant un peu sous
l'eau en la tenant toujours par la
couronne et surtout sans frotter pour
pas abîmer les ligaments ensuite vous
rincer la bouche vous respirer un grand
coup et vous remettez les racines dans
l'entrepôt impliqués et après vous
foncez quand même chez le dentiste
parce que il faut qu'ils fixent tout ça
et puis il ya le dernier cas de figure
le mien en l'occurrence vous ne
retrouvez pas là dans ces cas-là il ya
moins le feu mais très n'est quand même
pas trop pour les chez le dentiste
ne serait ce que pour faire une radio et
puis évidemment dans tous les cas si
vous vous êtes cassé les dents dans un
accident de la route ou quoi que ce soit
qui implique un choc très violent à la
tête
si vous avez perdu connaissance si vous
avez des vomissements vous appelez les
secours et ils vous emmènent aux
urgences à un dernier petit conseil si
c'est quelqu'un qui vous a cassé les
dents c'est par arriver
[Musique]
banks et a bien demandé un certificat
médical qui décrit les dégâts pour les
assurances en ce qui me concerne je
retourne demain celle attentif pour
vérifier si ce qui reste de mes dents et
viable et du cou pour voir ce qu'on peut
envisager en termes de restauration
restauration ça me donne un peu donc je
serai fixé demain
et évidemment je vous tiendrai au
courant non mais je vais tenter un truc
julien oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya comment ça
s'est passé demain ah ben je sors de
chez le dentiste justement alors le
programme bonne nouvelle d'abord pas
besoin de dévitaliser les dents on va
pouvoir réparer comme ça le programme ça
va être pour la dans la - cas c'est une
facette
c'est à dire des trucs qui recouvre la
dent pour faire comme si elle était
toute neuve et pour la dent la plus
cassée et une couronne à une prothèse de
couronnes dentaires comme comme prévu
donc rendez vous mardi dans une semaine
pour tailler tous a préparé le terrain
en faire les empreintes dentaires
rendez vous le mardi d'après pour poser
tout ça donc ça va assez vite ça va
coûter 1300 balle juste pour le matériel
sans compter les consultations que j'ai
déjà eu etc
il y aura une partie remboursée par la
sécu une partie renoncé par la mutuelle
je vous raconterai combien ça coûte au
final est pour aujourd'hui
autre pseudo bonne nouvelle il a fallu
que j'insiste un petit peu mais elle a
accepté de me faire un petit quelque
chose de temporaire une petite
réparation un peu à l'arraché avec du
composite
elle n'était pas chaude au départ parce
qu'elle pense que sa va pas tenir
mais bon vu que c'est pour une semaine
la semaine prochaine normalement j'aurai
encore un truc provisoire pour attendre
le rendez vous d'après donc pour une
semaine moi je j'achète c'est pas
parfait c'est même un peu voilà mais bon
ça ne l'a dégustée voit la dtcc fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous prenez soin
des autres et prenez soin de vos dents à
mettez vous bien et surtout parfait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]